[Music]
at roughly 4:00 p.m. on July 20th 1969
mahan kind was just minutes away from
landing on the surface of the Moon but
before the astronauts began their final
descent an emergency alarm lit up
something was overloading the computer
and threatened to abort the landing back
on earth Margaret Hamilton held her
breath she'd led the team developing the
pioneering in-flight software so she
knew this mission had no room for error
but the nature of this last-second
emergency would soon prove her software
was working exactly as planned
born 33 years earlier in Pao Lee Indiana
Hamilton had always been inquisitive in
college she studied mathematics and
philosophy before taking a research
position at the Massachusetts Institute
of Technology to pay for grad school
here she encountered her first computer
while developing software to support
research into the new field of chaos
theory next at MIT Lincoln Laboratory
Hamilton developed software for
America's first air defense system to
search for enemy aircraft but when she
heard the renowned engineer Charles
Draper was looking for help sending
mankind to the moon she immediately
joined his team NASA looked to Draper
and his group of 400 engineers to invent
the first compact digital flight
computer the Apollo guidance computer
using input from astronauts this device
would be responsible for guiding
navigating and controlling the
spacecraft at a time when unreliable
computers filled entire rooms the AGC
needed to operate without any errors and
fit in one cubic foot of space Draper
divided the lab into two teams one for
designing hardware and one for
developing software Hamilton led the
team that built the onboard flight
software for both the command and lunar
modules this work for which she coined
the term software engineering was
incredibly high stakes human lives were
on the line so every program had to be
perfect
Margaret software needed to quickly
detect unexpected errors and recover
from them in real time
but this kind of adaptable program was
difficult to build since early software
could only process jobs in a
predetermined order to solve this
problem
Margaret designed her program to be
asynchronous meaning the software's more
important jobs would interrupt less
important ones her team assigned every
task a unique priority to ensure that
each job occurred in the correct order
and at the right time regardless of any
surprises after this breakthrough
Margaret realized her software could
help the astronauts work in an
asynchronous environment as well she
designed priority displays that would
interrupt astronauts regularly scheduled
tasks to warn them of emergencies the
astronaut could then communicate with
Mission Control to determine the best
path forward this marked the first time
flight software communicated directly
and asynchronously with a pilot it was
these fail-safes that triggered the
alarms just before the lunar landing
Buzz Aldrin quickly realized his mistake
he'd inadvertently flipped the
rendezvous radar switch this radar would
be essential on their journey home but
here it was using up vital computational
resources
fortunately the Apollo guidance computer
was well equipped to manage this during
the overload the software restart
programs allowed only the highest
priority jobs to be processed
including the programs necessary for
landing the priority displays gave the
astronauts a choice to land or not to
land with minutes to spare Mission
Control gave the order the Apollo 11
landing was about the astronauts mission
control software and hardware all
working together as an integrated system
of systems Hamilton's contributions were
essential to the work of engineers and
scientists inspired by president john f
kennedy's goal to reach the moon and her
life-saving work went far beyond Apollo
11 no bugs were ever found in the
in-flight software for any crewed Apollo
missions after her work on apollo
hamilton founded a company that uses its
unique universal systems language to
create breakthroughs for systems and
software in 2003 NASA
honored her achievements with the
largest financial award they'd ever
given to an individual and 47 years
after her software first guided
astronauts to the moon Hamilton was
awarded the Presidential Medal of
Freedom for changing the way we think
about technology curious about coding
want to learn some of the basics of
programming check out our new series
think like a coder and help a girl and
her robot save the world and solve some
puzzles along the way
[Music]